welcome to the iced coffee hour this is
beat the bush and
uh
yeah let's roll with it i like it thank
you so much for coming all the way to
las vegas coming on our podcast i am
glad to be here this is a really special
episode for me because uh it's weird for
me to see you in person because i've
been watching your channel before i even
started youtube five years ago you were
one of the first people to make videos
about financial independence retiring
early investing you were like to me the
pioneer of the space why thank you i
look to your channel
but i looked at your channel when i
first started and i looked at the videos
you were making and like that was my
goal i loved your videos thank you thank
you and and those are all about
everything though so
that's not your goal
right you know what you're not thinking
of like doing like random videos like i
do no but your your original uh fire
videos your financial independence
retire early videos inspired me to talk
about the topic too and i looked at your
videos because i saw back then you were
getting like 20 30 000 views on some of
those videos and i was like wow there
are 20 000 people out there who want to
watch videos on youtube about retiring
early so in my mind i was like well if
you're getting 20 000 views i would have
a chance to then get uh let's say even
25 of that so like if i could get 5 000
people to watch my video on that uh you
kind of paved the way for me to follow
in your footsteps in the very beginning
and make videos about that topic
i appreciate that
wow
um
the one question i've always had i just
want to start here because you have i
think just such an interesting story and
you've taken a path that that most
people don't take you retired at a very
young age you were in the tech industry
you decided to go youtube full-time you
decided to work at an amazon facility uh
doing some odd jobs here and there but
you've remained somewhat retired this
entire time in your 30s the biggest
question i want to know is why did you
come up with the name beat the bush
when you start a youtube channel um well
at least when i started it it was not as
a finance channel i i decided to just
create something
um that is easy to remember just a
couple syllables and you know why it's
three syllables
because pewdiepie oh
my god
it's like hey pewdiepie oh okay you know
let me make something that is
you know very short right so
you know it's either be around the bush
okay let me shorten it beat the bush
right but then but then later on you
know people are like hey wait a minute
yeah that kind of has
different meanings here right i never
thought about that that dirty meaning
right i never came to my mind until like
until it's too late and then by the time
i had all these finance videos and stuff
people
kind of got attached to those they want
to watch those more yeah
then
it's like okay i gotta i gotta run with
that and that's the channel name so like
it wasn't like oh let me create a
finance channel let me let me think of a
name that is like
fire
uh bush or something right like that
right but it would also have another
meaning to it fireballers firebush so
it's like man i think many youtube
channels are
kind of
randomly named like that
and and you know not not started from
the very beginning so at what point did
you realize it's too late because i
remember i subscribed to you maybe it
you you were at like maybe 10 000
subscribers oh wasn't it oh yeah at the
very beginning uh and it was some of the
early i think it was maybe either the
fire the credit card videos that you had
posted way back it's like five years ago
and i remember thinking to myself eat
the bush i i knew you didn't have that
that meaning to it but i was like what
meaning what you guys keep pointing out
do you not understand i don't understand
are you serious i don't i know when you
then you could think dirty yeah jack
beat the bush
think
you could beat you could beat the bush
okay i feel like that's a stretch it's
like of course he wasn't like implying
something obviously like i've seen your
channel like i knew that but then the
name itself kind of makes you question
well
beat the bush okay that makes sense
that has gotten me into kind of i i
think it it has prevented me from kind
of
being more public i guess
right just the name itself because it's
like if someone mentions the channels
like what are you talking about you know
some sometimes people chuckle and stuff
right yeah i totally get that but you
know it's there
it's hard to change you know i could
change it
we'll see it wouldn't be the same give
us a little bit of your backstory here
because i know you retired early retired
we'll say in your 30s but walk us
through like how you're able to do that
you were living on almost nothing every
month you saved the vast majority of
your income earning a engineer's salary
right in the bay area that sounds worse
than than it is because you know i live
comfortably you know i i spend
an amount where you know i'm i'm eating
i'm paying the bills
it's it's not it's just that i'm not
living an extravagant life i don't like
jet everywhere i still i still do like
back when i was an engineer maybe like
two international trips a year still
okay i still keep my expenses really low
so what were you what was your process
like through like uh let's say college
did you go to college how were your
grades how did you land a job right
afterwards i went to ucla okay uh i
got really good grade straight days for
master's program i got pretty pretty
good grades and uh that's a double e
program
uh
you have to
do um internships a lot uh throughout
college in order to land a job
afterwards so that's what i did i worked
for
i think it's around 10 years as an
engineer
before i uh started youtube probably two
or three years before
i quit the last job
got it how much were you making
throughout that process
how much
uh
anywhere between 80 to 100
base salary okay
and then
you know there's there's rsus and stuff
that you add on top of that and you
started making that money right after
getting out of your master's program so
you're probably what like 25
yes
25 how were you paying for college at
the time
um
see my parents they didn't earn a lot so
i got uh student loans and student aid
i think
um to put things in this perspective i
owed about
uh twenty thousand dollars from
undergraduate it's not bad yeah from
ucla yeah for the entire thing so this
so then the rest of it is subsidies
about 20k was subsidies and
for master's program 20k was out of my
own pocket and i had 20k more debt just
from the master's program so
uh
at the end of it i had about 40k of debt
okay how long did that take you to pay
off and when you started working did you
go straight to the bay area because
that's expensive it's uh not cheap to
live there uh yes i mean my my parents
lived there
so then i just automatically moved back
oh did you live with your parents then
until you were able to pay off your debt
yeah and then you that's smart i think
more people and uh i pay i i didn't
really think about paying off debt like
at the time i was like okay i'm just
gonna i actually um there's a program
where they they allowed you to pay
minimum for four years and then they
ramp it up
so
uh that's what i did and i didn't really
like tackle that until years later where
i'm like hey i got i got a bunch of
money now let me just put some in in the
student loan so i got
i had this habit where like
if um i come back from a bar or
something and then i'll be like hey i'm
a little buzzed let me pay my student
life
i'm like
yeah so then you know when i do that
enough it's like oh okay it started
getting really little and then in the it
lasts like ten thousand dollars i'm like
whatever just
put it there just to make it go away and
because it's really
mentally taxing i guess to have a
have a bill come come in every single
month so i understand that so when you
moved out then
how did you balance a frugal lifestyle
did you were your parents frugal or
where did this come from
i try to think about
where this all came from i i i really
don't know like i got an allowance when
i was little
and i tended to save about 95 of it like
it was a small allowance
uh in hong kong it's like you get they
gave me two dollars two hong kong
dollars and you can buy one
drink one soda right and save most of
that
um
my siblings are not frugal like i am my
parents are not so
i think it's just mostly based on
um kind of like a relatively low income
family and then i'm like okay
i need to
i need to save and not splurge on yeah
maybe it's like a asian thing i don't
know i was the same way i
like neither of my parents were
necessarily like big savers but uh for
me i just i always like saving any
christmas money i would get uh holiday
birthday money whatever i wouldn't spend
it i purposely i put it in an envelope
in cash and i would just count it like
every week or so and then i'd be so
excited to add like a five dollar bill
to that
and uh and i would just sit there and
just count i just i liked it i did not
want to spend it
i do the same thing now yeah right like
instead of counting money i have a
spreadsheet that's interesting growing
up as a kid my parents always had to
tell me to not spend my money because i
would want to spend my money up until i
was like let's say maybe like 14 then i
started becoming pretty frugal but up
until then yeah i was like i definitely
wanted to buy the newest video game
always have like the best video game
console stuff like that but by the way
guys for everyone to understand everyone
knows how frugal graham is right
extremely frugal graham looks up to mr
bush beat the bush
for his level of frugality
and i see you going through these these
obstacles to save like what what i would
like five six dollars
and i look at that and it's like i i
wouldn't i used to i used to
follow that and i would do anything uh
now and not necessarily but i still look
to those videos because i find the uh
the sense of adventure adventure and
like uh
trying to save that extra like five six
dollars
i like that i like watching it
okay it's funny it's like entertainment
it's like
that's pretty fun looking like i'm not
gonna do that
myself it's too much for me
but i could live vicariously through you
i
look even i have rea this is just a
recent development i'm i'm like
but first guys this is huge we got a
sponsor coinbase hey alex do you
identify as crypto curious basically
meaning you've heard all the hype around
crypto it gets you excited but you're a
little too nervous to go and buy some
for yourself yeah actually i think the
biggest thing that stops me from buying
crypto is just all the complexity around
it it sounds very complicated to go and
get some crypto but coinbase makes it
extremely easy and it is the best buying
and selling platform for everything
crypto coinbase has some of the most
popular cryptocurrencies on the market
and they make it super easy and
accessible to everyone on a personal
note guys i actually started investing
in cryptocurrencies probably back in
2017ish and i actually got started on
coinbase four years ago and it has been
my main trading platform ever since and
i still hold all my coins there today
and i heard it's also super secure too i
heard that millions of people in over a
hundred different countries actually
trust coinbase with their digital assets
and i know you guys like free stuff just
like alex and i so coinbase is here to
help if you guys actually go to
coinbase.com
ich they will give you ten dollars in
free bitcoin super exciting wow i love
free bitcoin me too alex me too so sign
up at coinbase.com
ich to get your ten dollars in free
bitcoin this offers for a limited time
only so sign up today that's
coinbase.com ich for ten dollars in free
bitcoin thank you so much coinbase for
sponsoring this podcast and back to the
podcast
okay i have a video on uh making
uh almond milk right i'm like hey
everybody make all make your own almond
milk and then you know recently i'm like
okay
this is too much work so then i started
buying
you know like the commercial stuff so
then i saved that time how long would it
take for you to make like a pint of
almond milk uh i think it goes by two
cups and it takes me about five ten
minutes or so but then it's it's a lot
of hassle because you gotta get your
hands wet and you gotta yeah squeeze
so now it's a life of luxury for you is
what you're saying you're buying
i'm i'm only like picking out the the
really really
cringe-worthy frugal stuff right
and uh
generally i i i think
in retrospect it might have been a
mistake
to to to push that hard like you know
i'm sure it's some like character
development right like yeah like i mean
i'm changing
character development yeah so it's like
kind of like a
like a
morphing of myself i guess yeah
we'll come back to that i'm curious
though when you moved out on your own
do you you must know what your expenses
are i mean i've seen your spreadsheets
before we go over them on youtube you're
meticulous with your spending and your
expenses what were your expenses like
when you first moved out 40 000 about 20
24 or 25 000 was the mortgage and then
the rest was expenses yeah and you wait
so you bought a place you never rented
you went straight to saving
bought a place yeah that was the whole
idea smart that's the whole idea with my
parents i think they're they're the one
that goes you gotta buy a house you
gotta buy house you gotta buy a house
and uh so they're like stay at home stay
at home
uh save money give you great advice save
save for the down payment and that i did
and you know
i did have to pay for rent in college
for like you know a few years and stuff
so
but right after you know you get the
house and yeah and then you get you get
a head start yeah that's what i did with
uh my son jack
i told him live at home
and uh i gave jack free rent no you
didn't well
three hundred dollars a month for 300
months but yes for basically for
utilities so whatever jack was using up
is basically just like that's what i'd
want back
uh yeah so minuscule minuscule right but
i was just like you got it to save save
save so i did that and i've never
officially technically kind of rented my
own apartment or place so now i've just
went straight into buying yeah
it's a good it's a great thing to do
yeah yeah like i mean especially um i
mean it worked for the past 10 years
at least for with real estate prices
going on yes so when did you buy 10
years ago 2011 2010.
that's like the bottom of the market so
that's why i say i'm lucky you know wow
that's like that was right at the time
where i saved just enough to buy but
because right before the the downturn
i didn't have enough to to to buy a
house wow so like it came down and then
i'm like yes now it's my chance and then
i jump in and and then you know it it it
only went up from there so what price
did you buy it for
uh five
five ten
twenty or so now
yeah now it's double
wow
i would imagine it would be worth
because it's a town house right it's
yeah
yeah so it's like uh two two
units with the same wall yeah i don't
know what you call that yeah like kind
of like a dupe yeah well townhouse but
uh that's incred i would imagine it
would be worth more like one one right
now one two around there
depending on the
on the uh
what do you call the
the estimate of yeah
you know the i use zillow and then it
just kind of goes up and down in in
terms of their estimates got it okay um
is the mortgage paid off right now yes
it is
geez
wow and what
age did you said to retire because i
that was the big thing for me when you
decided to be like you know i'm going to
quit my job i have enough in investments
what age were you what prompted you to
take a step back because i would say at
the current trajectory if you were
making 120 plus rsu's
keep that up a little bit longer than
it's that you're at 200 pretty quickly
um 250. how do you walk away from that
because i saw that
youtube could
could replace
an engineering income completely and for
a while it did
and then
i decided to like i only realized that i
could retire
uh sometime after i did full-time
youtube so it's like and then and then
you know that that's like a dangerous
thing this whole fire thing i i'd say
it's
people really have to take that with a
grain of salt because i kind of use
myself as a
as a guinea pig of sorts right because
i'm like oh i'm i'm working i need to
retire retire retire and i'm after i
retire i can do nothing and and just sit
around and
and be lazy
do whatever i want right and that's
that's essentially what i did
and uh
i'm glad to say that i've been through
it yeah and and i can say that it's not
that fun
to do whatever you want i want to hear
about that experience how old were you
when you decided to do that okay so
now i am how am i
it's 2 000
i am 41 right now i would never have
gotten man you look young thank you
sunblock
that's amazing keep selling sunscreen
and now it's bad because now i'm getting
the uh i don't know if you could see it
yet like when i when i do this point
lines yeah i see the squint lines like
they they last longer like before when i
was young like when i was 20 i could do
this and they'll go away immediately but
nice oh no
it's bad i don't like it
so
uh that must have been about two years
ago where a year and a half or ago where
like
um i decided hey you know i'm just going
to try to um
i i caught myself doing trying to do as
little as possible on youtube
that's i'm guilty yeah it's charged you
might you might have noticed you're like
yeah everybody has noticed they're like
hey how come what are you doing
you know how come there's less videos
how come the quality and all that you
know yeah well i'll tell you from my
perspective i think uh you went
full-time youtube and you were posting a
new video every day right yes so so then
i hustled like crazy while i was at work
uh engineering job for the
uh one year before i quit yeah i hustled
about a year after
and then afterwards i'm like
hey look you know i could i could do
nothing
so then i think that kind of got into my
head
what did you do all day when you were
doing nothing
think about life
uh
at first you know you can do whatever
you want so you know
watch a bunch of shows yeah i love i
watched star trek it was fun
i watched all of them nice all of them
that i wanted to watch right and uh
and then and then you i i i think about
like minimalism yeah right trying to
declutter trying to think about
you know what's the meaning of life
you know you get kind of deep into that
and then
i think i think
if you can
listen to someone else you know it's
probably better to to to like go oh i
want to retire and go do it yourself for
two years and then realize that it's
kind of kind of boring kind of sucks and
then but first we want to thank
grammarly for sponsoring this episode of
the iced coffee hour podcast recently
graham has been looking for ways to save
some time around the office here and he
quickly realized it's actually the
little things that add up especially in
the long run so in light of this he's
gonna actually be banning bathroom
breaks water breaks and that was a joke
right i i think so i hope so all right
guys we're just kidding about that but
seriously something like writing can
take up a lot of time especially if you
want to be the best it can be graham is
always writing scripts for the main
channel and recently we installed
grammarly on his computer now he can
right away to his little heart's content
and get real-time feedback it's like
having a professional writer look
through your work whenever you want with
grammarly premium you can get clarity
suggestions which will help you get your
point across quickly without using
unnecessary or redundant words and they
also provide vocab suggestions to
replace overused words and phrases and
they have tons more amazing features
that make writing easier than ever so
hit send with confidence and get your
point across more effectively with
grammarly premium get twenty percent off
grammarly premium at grammarly.com
iced coffee that's g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y
dot com slash iced coffee so thank you
so much grammarly for sponsoring this
episode and back to the podcast
my impression was that you were more
like a homebody who i am and i'm yeah
i don't know how much introvert you are
but like i am i'm more i'm probably more
introverted than both of you combined i
don't know about that i don't know about
that i if if i don't have to leave the
house for a week straight i i don't
think it would be one yeah you can't be
because you you're inviting me over to
yeah you have this that's true i guess
so yeah but but you know um
i'm
i'm so much so that um i haven't done
these podcasts before yeah i know this
is the first one i think right one like
yeah yeah i think i did i i did one
other not really a podcast was more like
a collaboration but that's like a rare
rare thing and i've got
um and and and if anybody's watching
that have invited me i'm
deeply apologized because i'm
super introverted i'm like i just want
to stay at home i don't want to talk to
anybody we tried doing this two years
ago i mean it didn't work oh yeah
but that was that i didn't see that as
your fault i think our timing was just
kind of off that time i think you were
out of town for one weekend that we were
going up to the area to visit a house
nearby
uh yeah um i i chuck you i would chuck
cut that towards me being kind of in
like two introverts it was like like
yeah
that's right now i could tell because uh
right before covet hit i saw your video
of you prepping you called it by the way
you said that like a few months before
yes you said i think it was about a
month before you said there's no way
we're not going into lockdown they're
gonna do this so i'm gonna prepare
myself ahead of time so you locked down
two weeks prior to everyone else and you
called it people are like you're crazy
yeah but you were right now i don't know
of like uh you know that extra two weeks
on top of everything else but i guess it
didn't matter but you know at least it
lets you buy supplies but
in the end the supplies didn't matter
too much yeah because it didn't it
didn't pan out to be as crazy as i
thought right so about a year and a half
ago two years ago is when you said that
you decided to go like take it easy off
of youtube and then you weren't working
at the time you wanted to just basically
full-on uh retire
uh i
i think it's more it's not something i
decided it was kind of like
i i my mind just kind of fell into it
you know like i was kind of like why am
i hustling so hard why am i
you know doing this doing that you know
i just got i just got lazy it's like
when you have when when the
when your retirement number reached its
point
your goal right you're like oh i'm there
let me let me take a break
you know what it is it's diminishing
returns it's like in the very beginning
going from like one to two you doubled
going from two to four you doubled but
when you have a hundred going from 100
to 101
not quite the same enjoyment is going
from one to two once it reached there
it's like oh
i don't have to do anything i just
let the
you know just try to invest it and
let it ride and i can i can just scoop
off yeah now you've had some really good
investments and some really bad
investments
uh the one investment i remember you
making was in bitcoin yeah can you tell
us about this um that was just more of a
coincidence again um
because
when i was
because a lot of subscribers just kept
on asking me for bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin
so like at you know after like months of
this right i'm like okay fine i'm gonna
look into it so i finally looked into it
and i got some and then it turns out um
you know it skyrocketed what price did
you find after it was kind of like
gradual like i forget
two thousand
3 000 or something but then i ended up
selling at like
1750 right
but that was a i don't know five five i
remember it was a 5x game yeah so um
you know it's a nice chunk of change
because the the total i made wasn't that
much i didn't put like
you know multiple tens of thousands or
something i think
i i made a total of
20 30k or something like that that's
still fantastic though that's a good
return
yeah
wow
you know did you ever buy back in
bitcoin uh no
what do you think of it now
um
it's kind of high you think so it's kind
of i don't i don't know i don't know
like i i
um
uh it's kind of stable so then it's not
something i i want to put my money in
for huge returns
uh
yes
because
because there's the other cryptocurrency
that i bought into but yeah
yeah so what prompted you put a lot of
money in dogecoin um
what prompted me
why it was i think it made the headlines
in the news
when it did the first ramp up to around
five cents it went from one cent to five
cents and then that was
also a coincidence because i was like i
need i need something that will get me a
roadster do you want a roadster by the
way i would if he's ever gonna release
it but i don't think he's gonna release
it listen i think i think the roadster
was always this little carrot he was
dangling in front of all the tesla
owners
and here's the thing i think the
roadster came out what like seven years
six years ago like the first designs of
it it was a while ago and i think now
the car looks outdated unfortunately i
think the entire car has to now be
redesigned and i don't think there's any
way he's gonna sell that car for 250.
i don't think so not when the plaid is
selling for 150. i don't think i don't
think he's able to manufacture this car
for 250.
not a hundred thousand that's the that's
the founders edition that's the founders
edition but even 200 i just
i think it's got to be more than that i
don't think the battery is capable of
doing 500 miles i don't think uh
uh
i don't i i think he has to improve the
car in so many ways because right now
the plaid zero to 60 in under two
seconds
this roadster has to do that in one
point seven it's it's got it's gotta be
now what they're gonna do they're gonna
sprinkle some magic on it
my guess is my guess is at some point
they're probably gonna cancel the
roadster
um refund money which is gonna be a
nightmare but they're going to come up
with something else or they're going to
say if you put a deposit down on this
we'll offer you either the money back or
you could get first in line on this next
car that we're coming out with i think
it's got to be it has to same with the
cyber truck i've been saying this for a
while i i think the cyber truck is such
a long way from actually being a road
worthy car and i put down a deposit on
that just for fun if they if they come
out with a cyber truck i'll get one but
i just don't think it's going to happen
same with the roadster
yeah so
so about the roadster i was like i
really want one so then i
decided to find somewhere to invest that
would have huge gains
and dogecoin uh kind of fit the
my criteria that's why i put money in it
and i and i'm like okay dogecoin it
looks like
uh you can do
what was it it can do like fivefold
reasonably or whatever number of fold
right so i'm like that that has a good
chance of of doing what i wanted to do
so that's why i
invested in that how much you put in
initially
what was it like
50k right now i have about 72k in it so
i have a even number of around a million
dogecoins wow
but
what prompts you to do that's a because
that is a risky investment and it could
just as easily go from five cents down
to a penny
why
why risk so much money
i didn't see it as a risk it didn't
i saw i saw it as
i saw the risk as
highly reduced because i i saw all the
things match up is like elon musk
but
you know and and
that's probably the main thing
yeah
and uh
i don't know i looked into it and
i mean it it worked out right now it's
still like plus 200 or so so you have
not sold it
do you have plans to sell it or are you
waiting for that one year and you get
long-term capital gains one year and
then i'll see what happens i i i feel
like if i wait long enough
it might do another
another um what do you call skyrocketing
sure thing whatever
whatever ramp up that it does
it might happen and if it does then i
can be there to receive
do you think it'll reach a dollar
i
i uh maybe okay
but i think i i don't know like i can't
predict the future right i don't know if
dogecoin is gonna it's gonna do that but
i always think that you need to put
something somewhere to to to get lucky
right you gotta you gotta put your what
do you call it like place your bets kind
of yeah sure if you don't if you don't
have
a couple things everywhere you know just
so that you have the possibility of
something like that happening then
you're it's never gonna happen
so why don't you put a little money in
bitcoin right now
because it's
i know i know it did really well okay
like like it went from
what was it is it like 30 40k or
something not 60 yeah
one in 35 days
sometimes you can't catch them you can't
catch them all
right i i miss the sheba
yeah
oh yeah
like what do you think of that yeah oh
yeah well maybe if i like put all my
doge point at the time into sheba oh my
gosh and then
then i have a yacht or something yeah
you would have probably 20 million
dollars had you just moved doge going to
sheba three weeks ago
yeah or like
even longer it's ridiculous right
um
yeah
so you there's a lot of misopportunity
but the hard thing is to find find out
which one and sometimes something that
you would actually
follow through and and actually invest
yeah so far every bet that i've made on
that i call them bets because that's
what they are they're bets uh everyone
has lost money so usually i'll tie these
bets to how many likes a video will get
and so i did this with dogecoin i did
this with amc
and i did this recently with sheba you
know and so i bought uh one was i think
ten thousand dollars of amc i bought
that that's down like 30 but i'm just
gonna hold that i don't care uh the
other one was ten thousand of dogecoin i
think i'm down thirty five percent of
that too and then uh i bought shibuya
guess how many shiba inus they bought
ten thousand dollars worth of like
how many how many of them like a billion
one billion
not quite i'll just tell you i'll just
tell you
260 something
a million
shiba inu coins
it was like 75 000. that's a lot of call
260 million how has that treated you
uh
i think i'm i'm down a little bit like
briefly but
i said i was gonna hold it for a year
and i'm intending to hold it for a year
but i also set a limit order
to sell just in the event those are
honest so that way i don't have to think
about it but i set a very high limit
where i'd essentially like if i double
my money i'd be stupid not to sell it so
it's like it's there i'm not going to
sell it but you know it could happen it
could very easily happen yeah so because
i've lost money on everything else and
like at least if this does well i don't
want to lose money on this i need
something to just hold me over on the
others now i might tax loss harvest uh
dogecoin at the end of the year because
if i'm down i could use that to at least
offset something else and buy back in
lower my cost basis on that same with
amc
but uh yeah they've not gone well for me
i'm sorry to hear ah it's okay it's okay
the other thing i want to bring up to
you you got a job working at an uh
amazon facility
yes
that was fun and how about a waste of
time don't ever do that
what made you do that that's the whole
that's the whole look i i think i've
come to the realization
that
uh i don't know i don't know why i did
this but i i felt like i've wasted a lot
of time
like
uh
this this has to do with like the whole
whole being too frugal type of thing
well that that's a waste of time too
uh so i never thought i would hear you
saying
this is new you got it you got it you
got to make a video on this
if if you talked to me maybe a month ago
this is not what i would say what
changed
it's the job really yeah like like i
guess maybe it's like it's kind of like
uh what do you call those things
pilgrimage to those guys that goes to
yeah sure the temples and stuff whatever
that is right is like going to the
amazon job is is like a transformative
experience i guess tell us about that if
that is if that is the case
then it is worth it
right i would yeah i would start to
interrupt i would have the opposite
experience because how much were you
making at amazon 15.25 that would make
me more appreciative of like not
spending money because i'm like if if
this is the alternative of working
really hard for 15 an hour
that means that me going and getting
chipotle with guacamole and extra meat
is 15. that's an hour of my life now
that's not how you think about it but
that's how i thought of it this is how
you i thought about it which is
um
this is
this is so such hard work
i worked three shifts of four hours each
before i thought this is not fun anymore
because you know i don't i don't know if
you want to know the details i just
scanned stuff yeah i do i want to yeah
what do you do um
you you um
you either do
a thing called ambient or a thing called
chilled which is in in the refrigerator
right
what you basically do you have a car you
open up some bags and then the little
scanner tells you where to get the item
so you go you go you go to the location
because it tells you exactly where it is
and then and then you scan the location
and it goes okay you got to get this
these three items of the same thing so
you pick it out you scan those and you
put it in the bag
repeat
uh until everything is
complete you close the bag and put it on
the shelf
uh all this is you know it goes step by
step if the scanner tells you what to do
um
but after doing this for
what three shifts i think i started
feeling feeling like this is
this is really hard work
this is like getting me like sore like
after after every shift right i'm i'm
like i just can't do anything else the
rest of the day i'm just kind of like i
i needed that reminder
of how hard it is to to earn money
now i'm curious why can't that be
replaced with a robot it seems like if
all you're doing is grabbing one item
putting it over here
why haven't they developed that that's
got to be automated
uh i think that partly is because
the the items themselves are in strange
shapes and it's really hard to do
robotics to grab things like like chips
that might be hard because you might
crush chips
uh if you if you do eggs you need to
somehow open the eggs so check all the
eggs
and put rubber bands on them and got it
okay
right the the handling i guess maybe
they just haven't gotten the the
robotics for the hands figured out
so you said you worked three shifts
right three or four shifts to the side
in total i worked eight eight shifts and
how long were was each shift four four
hours each so you weren't 32 hours and i
had two
training days of four and a half hours
before i started this shift and then you
realize this is not for me and you just
said after the third shift i'm like this
this is really
this is really not for me
so uh i'm not sure how if i'm gonna do
something similar like that again yeah
right but why why take that job versus
i'm gonna make a youtube video and in
the same time we'll make five times that
that amount
um
why take that job
instead um because i thought it was
interesting like the first three shifts
was very very interesting for me i think
it was worth it
but after that it was a waste of time
right because see look i learned
all about it right i get to go there i
was actually
happy and excited to go and get
interviewed or
was there an interview i forget
there's basically not much you just take
your picture and stuff right and make
sure um do a drug drug test yeah
and uh
yeah after after uh the learning about
it is is is worth the time got it so i i
i really wasted
five shifts
20 hours and during the application
process when you i'm sure you spoke to
somebody right like did they see your
resume and think that maybe like hey
this guy's a little over qualified i was
literally i
this guy's a master
i
only retired i only graduated high
school on my resume so i no way so i
omitted it omitted everything why do you
think that they wouldn't have hired me
no they would definitely uh just in case
they didn't
you know i cuz i wanted to go have some
fun
so that was it
so what was your like objective with
going and getting this job it was just
to learn a new experience spice up your
life a little bit and see what happens
yes
i
remember i did i did the same thing with
a couple of other jobs too
what were some of the other jobs amazon
warehouse yeah
uh uber
door dash
and i worked at my friend's
these dumpling place where they wrap
glutinous rice with uh leaves yeah it's
really hard to do yeah so it took me two
full days of to learn this
and how long i learned it how long did
you work each of these jobs was it still
like quick turnover like you know eight
shifts yeah well the
history here yeah so so the the dumpling
take place is uh two days
uh uber i did it for a week doordash
couple days
and it's all just for the experience
nothing has to do with the money or
anything
uh well it's nice to get paid a little
bit
but yeah mostly to try it out and how
does this give you a new appreciation
for money seems like your mentality
towards this is completely different to
grams
uh how does it how does it make you make
you want to spend more and live a little
more luxury
um
it made me realize that i was wasting my
time
because because i could be earning more
um either engineering
if if they would hire me back i don't
think they will now by the way why
because i've been out of the job
workforce for too long it's been like
three years
is that really that long three years
even four i'm sure you could do an entry
level something i mean it's three it's
at least three that's that bad i don't
but i don't know engineering
they don't like people that that kind of
start a youtube channel and went rogue
got it right yeah
so
um
yeah so
you realize that you could be making a
lot more money doing another job and
that's somehow how you realized you
should spend more money
correct um so then i realized that
it was a waste of time to do that
if i wasted my time
packing groceries what else am i wasting
my time on
right so that that kind of like
translated to other things where like
you know if i'm like pinching pennies
and stuff that's wasting time too so
like that kind of got me like that kind
of flipped the switch this is like
a whole new no i now i understand that
right yeah so it's basically upon
choosing to spend your time on more
things that you really enjoy
doing
um no
it's more about
the most effective use of your time i
think
like not really
like
most enjoyment but like
you know i i i could be i could be doing
something else earning
you know 50 an hour right
and
i can use that money to pay for whatever
instead so why why would i waste my time
doing something that that only saves
let's say 30 dollars an hour
but with this newfound like idea of
money are you going to go and get a high
paying job and then start paying for
these smaller like luxuries no i don't
have to right because i'm
i'm still retired
but um
but i might make more youtube videos so
i am curious what sort of youtube videos
you want to make i have to say a few of
your videos that were my favorite were
the ones where you would post them and
i'd look at this and be like i can't
believe this is a video
and a few examples of that would be uh
one putting on pants without you without
using your arms
[Music]
wait
put on your pants with no hands yes i
gotta show you this jack uh i don't even
know if it's still
uh public basically it's it's like this
viral trend a couple years ago where um
this guy he
he have these pants that's are just kind
of scrunched up on on the floor
that makes it easy for him to put them
on so he's like
just with his boxers on
you know and and then he and then he
puts his leg in to to put the pants on
you can't use your hands and so you kind
of just kind of like
you know kind of move wiggle around
until the the pants needs to get above
you know get to your waist so that's
i don't know that's fun it was like a
seven minute video of uh
struggling of you putting on pants
without hands and this is like you would
go from like investing bitcoin financial
independence and then i think and
what was really funny is that you posted
a video like a few days prior to this
being like i retired or like quit my job
or something like that and this is like
the second video after that we got his
pants for seven minutes and someone
commented like the top comment was like
this is what early retirement is like
i loved that video there were a few
others that i really liked and i want to
go to your channel right now to talk
about them
because i thought some of these were so
creative
uh videos like how to fix a hole in your
jeans
oh yeah that's like a diy one
yep uh i like this one
uh how i saved a hundred percent of my
job income
beat the bush and i that inspired one of
my videos of uh i think it was how i
save a hundred percent of my income
it was an old video i think a few years
ago but but your video inspired that one
and uh i like this how to fix a zipper
50 seconds long
uh i like it
this one
a seven minute video explaining urinal
etiquette and look at this there's a
there's three urinals a b and c and if
someone's using a
you never use b
this is something
what are you serious jack no there's
always serious dude we gotta give you
the quiz yeah it's like but it's like
first of all i would never think that
this would need to be explained it's
it's just i think men are known
does this result from some poor
experience that you may have had like
well that resulted from some stuff i've
saw somewhere else
with a similar idea but and i decided to
make it into a video there's there's a
harder one right you need to get into
the more advanced questions right if you
have four urinals right and then and
then there's there's a big guy on the
first one and then there's a skinnier
guy on the on the last one which one do
you use i wait
believe it or not i i do not usually
use the third one i don't do that you
probably go next to the skinnier guy
honestly yeah yeah yeah but here's the
goal no the worst part the worst part is
because i wear a lot of flip-flops and
uh if you
use a urinal next to someone and you're
wearing
yeah
nasty i'm just saying believe it or not
the top of your shoes
may have some residue
on them particles
yeah and i i've had it a couple times
where i went flip-flops next to someone
and i did feel something so now i i no
longer i i will wait if i'm wearing flip
flops did you like it
well i think that's i should answer that
on a different
form of media you're
wow did i like it i can't believe you
yeah i purposely waited the question i
keep emergency flip-flops uh in my back
pocket just to switch into you can just
put some paper towel on and then go in
so
i
shield i try to avoid ever using your
urine i do not like urinals so you use
the stall yes dude come you put up the
seat though right
most of the time but here's the thing
dude i'm going to be honest with you if
the seat is disgusting then get toilet
paper and grab the seat and move it off
listen it's not my i'm not going to
clean someone else's mess everywhere
like something so what if everyone was
like you though if okay so here's the
thing if if the toilet's clean i leave
it spotless but if there's already
something on there i don't clean it
because they're not some of them are
nasty like really disgusting i do not
want to flip up a urinal where there's
toilet paper and like just just matter
on the seat itself like i'm not gonna
touch that thing i'm not getting
anywhere close to that i just want to
get in and out in private i don't know i
think that there is a net benefit and
you have to leave a net positive there
graham you have to lift up that seat you
got to put it up i leave the same
position
yeah you have to have a net positive i
leave your action i leave it the same as
i go in
no you leave it worse because obviously
if the seat's down there has to be some
splatter damage on the seat alright
maybe
um a few of your other videos i liked
this one the importance of looking poor
yeah that was popular one that was one
of your most uh uh viewed videos
so people like that one i don't know why
is this it turned out to be a comedy but
it wasn't meant to be one yeah it was it
was serious but i think that's why
people liked it was because
you approached this topic that
people first of all wouldn't think about
but it makes sense when i see that i'm
like it it makes sense to me not to in
certain situations not to overdress or
not to appear wealthy and you approached
it with a very uh uh tactile approach uh
that to me made made sense but i think
for people who didn't know you or know
the context they would go into this
being like ah then just dismiss it the
other video i liked of yours is that uh
going back to the frugality aspect is
that uh
you went on a trip
with your tesla
and it was you didn't want to spend i
think the fifty dollars a night for a
hotel and so you i think you spent a few
nights in the in the car
um that was
uh
did i do that in the tesla yeah oh maybe
maybe it wasn't the tesla
um i did
did i did some experiments in the tesla
since but then i think the that video
must have been in a white bmw
where i kind of like toured went through
grand canyon and all that and i just
kind of slept in the car the whole time
yeah uh
now how much of that was to save money
versus how much was just this is good
content for youtube
i think probably
i don't know 80 to save money i think it
was like mainly like i wanted to do it
and because because it's a really long
trip it was like you know the longer it
is the more expensive it gets if you
stay at hotels and um
staying in your car is also very
convenient
yes and uncomfortable true uh i did one
i did one when i went to maui i stayed
in the car i don't know if you know
about that one but uh it got a little
dangerous
because because i had to roll the
windows down and uh
uh a random person
uh came and stole my food that was
uh in my car no wait came and robbed me
you you were in the car when the food
was stolen i was asleep
and because it was really hot in maui
and the window was down he kind of
reached in and then after after he took
the stuff i don't know why i'm talking
about this yeah i know it's interesting
but uh but but he woke me up and then
he's like hey you know i got he has my
bread and peanut butter and then i got
really angry and got out and like
confronted him and took it back
no but but he woke you up like you were
sleeping and he so he took it and then
woke you up to show you what he's doing
yeah wait what yeah yeah yeah he woke me
up and then i don't know what he
he wanted some water
on top of that so he's like this peanut
butter and bread isn't enough
but obviously the guy's not have sound
mind why he was why
why get it back why not to say it's
peanut butter and bread i'm gonna give
this guy the thing just to go away
because what if what if he was like
wanted to fight you or you got in a
fight or like he had a weapon or like i
think part of the reason that made me
go do it was because he didn't look that
threatening to me okay like i i felt
like i
you know if it comes down to i might be
able to take him on
is it worth it
i don't know
like if if he showed some kind of
dangerous things i might have backed off
right
but he didn't look threatening and
yeah
probably not the best decision at the at
the moment but uh but anyway he slipped
in the card there too um all that was an
experiment and i i if you
anybody slept in the car before yeah oh
yeah
i i think on uh
i've probably taken a nap in the car but
never like overnight
it's very uncomfortable because it's not
flat so you learn a lot about flatness
you know if you if you park your car on
a
steep
hill or something like you can't sleep
very well
and then like the the incline of the
back seat if they're if it's slightly
tilted you can't sleep well either
so
not very comfortable maybe in the
tesla's okay i
the tesla um the back seat also it has
like a few degrees so you gotta like
make it so what are some of the frugal
things that you used to do that you
think now would just be a bad idea
uh one time i try to
uh not have internet
how do you do that being a youtuber
right but um
i use some sort of like back then they
had some kind of like ymax thing so then
i had like multiple
um
uh
accounts
and then you can add up to a lot of data
because each one does like i don't know
how many megabytes 200 megabytes yeah or
one gigabyte is like okay i use this one
okay i finished using this one okay i'll
switch to the next one bad idea
but
um
and another one is like i tried
unplugging the microwave for a while
did you did it did you see anything
like like for for i think i did it for
like a couple weeks or something and
then i realized this is like i hate
doing that it's too much time what is
the energy that it's doing is it just
like that clock on it
yes it's like a standby power so it's
one watt
for
continuously
over
an entire month i forget what what the
what the numbers are
is it a watt an hour one watt an hour uh
one watt
uh so then if it's for if you have it on
for an hour it's one watt hour so 24
watts a day times 30 so 600 so how much
would that cost all right so that's
about let's say that's about one
kilowatt hour
one and that costs about 25 cents yeah
so
you're basically you're basically
getting paid a penny per day no per day
because you probably have to do it a
couple of times a day oh yeah so each
time you do it is
less than half a penny so
i didn't really do that for very long
like i just tried it but there's there
are there are many of these things i i
think
you know you you gotta push too hard if
you want to
save a lot of money you gotta push a
little too hard and then when you and
then and then and then you realize that
you pushed a little too hard it was it's
too much then you come back a little bit
you know what i loved those videos that
you did because i'm always curious in
the back of my mind how much you would
save by doing that and you've done these
videos you've broken them down a perfect
example of this
and there's so many videos of yours that
i'd like i sincerely really like a lot
and one of them was uh the shower video
how much you would save by not taking a
shower at your house and instead using
water at the gym
and i think you calculated yeah i think
i think you calculated it was about 25
cents a day is how much you would save
if you took one shower a day at the gym
oh yeah i think i had to add in the cost
to heat the water because that is the
major cost and then you got to look at
um the cost to heat the water i think it
comes in like therms or something right
and then you gotta do like okay what's
the typical ambient temperature of the
water to the water temperature that
you're using the engineering degree
right and then and then it flows through
the pipes and it drops several degrees
i love those videos and i think if you
made more videos like that on topics
that people would just be curious about
not necessarily do
right but that's always been in the back
of my mind if
uh when i was going to the gym i used to
go to 24 hour fitness and i'd go every
single morning i was thinking well i'd
never really use the gym there what
happens if i just use the shower there
how much would i save by doing that i
wouldn't probably do it but i would just
be curious what that would add up a lot
of people do that yeah i think in my uh
when i was in engineering
some of my coworkers would shower at
work um yeah and some people shower at
the gym the one i'd be curious about you
might have a video about this is how
much you would save if you
waited all day to flush the toilet like
only one flush a day like i told i told
jack jack was flushing that when uh when
he was in the guest house he's flushing
the toilet too much
there's no such thing as flushing the
toilet two minutes you never you never
calculate how much it costs to flush
once i was i i calculated that i think
it was about a penny a flush i
calculated it first of all and it was
just under a penny perfect it was under
because because we had a three gallon
flush so i'm like it's three gallons of
water perfectly it wasn't a low flow
it's about i calculated about half a
penny per
flush or per gallon per gallon that's
what i i calculated as well
so that's so one and one cents yeah was
it three gallons but yeah
that's not a that's not a love float you
can you can flush all day long and it
won't dent anything
right so he he told me this while he's
still making like five million dollars a
year
i mean he's and and i walk out of the
bathroom he's all hey man i you know
look is there any chance maybe you can
just like tone it down with the flushes
maybe like if you're peeing just don't
flush it because that's what i do i mean
i i guess you could but dude if you pee
it sometimes it leaves a ring around the
toilet and then like don't wait that
long yeah
yeah it causes a smell
no there's no but there is an odor but
how much you drink like uh like macy
makes these these smoothies and i have
one of these smoothies and i swear i
have to go like every 20 minutes after
that for the next two hours and so now
i've purposely um i had to drink i wait
to drink the smoothies during a time
where like i'm not as busy because i
just have to mentally like i have to go
every 20 minutes afterwards
i don't know but but during that time
i'm not gonna be like flash flash flash
flash but it seems like a waste
i saw i saw a video he did where
he turned a
reusable
uh to the flosser into a or he yeah he
made a one-time flosser into a reusable
you and that's how i knew that i liked
you bring up these embarrassing things
now i look back at them and i'm like you
know that that might have been i like
all of those videos you really like them
you have to understand i think for your
audience that's what makes you you
and when i see a video like that i watch
it from beginning to end
because these are all things that like
people kind of think about in the back
of their mind but they don't do it but
they're not going to do but you do it
and we could experience that it's like
extreme cheapskates those videos get
millions of views everyone loves it i
love it especially i get ideas see but
people some people make fun of it i get
i watch those videos and i get ideas
like the person who uh reused their uh
their not their toilet paper but the uh
the the paper towels
makes sense they dry out they're just as
good if it's just water it's true sure
yeah
seriously no with paper towels i mean
it's a lot of time with paper towels if
i do a whole thing of paper towel and
i'm just cleaning off water i usually
leave it i don't throw it away because
yeah but you know what that means macy's
gonna walk or i'm gonna walk in there
i'm gonna see a paper towel i'm like
well i don't know what this was used to
clean up and i'll throw it away
just leave it
just leave it alone
okay now for water and stuff like that
it makes it if i'm just cleaning up
water
and leave it there but another few hours
it's dry i'd do it again dry your hands
after you washed your hands and you dry
it with water oh yeah i don't use paper
towels to dry my hands i use that towel
yeah
don't even dry him oh i just wanted to
bring up the whole idea of like when you
finally decided to quit and he's a
little bit off of youtube all of this
free time that you had you spent it you
said thinking about life and just kind
of like sitting around and not doing
much and you said it wasn't very
fulfilling
it
it always it always feels like i'm about
to come up with something like i'm i'm
coming to a
new epiphany kind of right it's like oh
i'm
i'm gonna
it it feels like you're almost there but
then
nothing really
happens i guess right
um
like if you ask me you know what what's
the result of all of that it's just like
well it's
it it might be because
it might be that if you retire you're
going to have too much time to think and
it's it's just going to drive yourself
crazy
it's better to to have something to do
i'd say
so your average day nowadays is kind of
just like can you walk me through it
um
average day
i wake up i drink milk tea that's my
drink of preference and
i
read some news
i uh
i might jot down some ideas for videos
um because because i i i
suddenly became a little bit more active
in in making more videos now so so then
i've changed but if you're asking about
what i did
you know when i was lazy
that's that's that's
much different i think you're asking
about that right
um being lazy means uh
scrimping on
stuff that
because because when you're lazy and and
you don't do much then you end up not
earning much
and then you also
um
kind of
i guess my hobby is kind of like
scrimping i guess you know saving money
here and there like ooh
um
uh this this deal whatever deal i go go
and get that deal and you know i can
like be really on top of it it's like
they have something and you have to like
sometimes you have to like get it right
away
right or else it disappears
so you know i can be on top of that and
just kind of
do small money things
which
i would say
many of my subscribers hate yeah but you
spent all this time thinking about the
life and like and the purpose of life
what what what is your
what have you figured out about that
meaning of life
yeah
what's the meaning of life
um
you know
i guess
i'm not gonna have like you know an
answer for that like right off
it's like
you know i can allude you to
the maslow's
uh hierarchy
like
uh
self-actualization
but then
you know do doing something that that
that you're good at that can
uh provide that can help other people
that can make you money and all that
then you know if you if you if you do
that then you can feel fulfilled
it's more about like it's also about
like what are you happy doing right but
you you can't be happy just
doing entertaining things
you can't like
entertain yourself and and like
go on vacations all the time
um
just indulging in stuff
like it's it it's much better to kind of
work at something i think like
it
there's a longer you can do it for a
longer duration you can do it for really
long if you work at something because
it's satisfying to to to work at
something versus you know if you're a
tourist
if you
i don't i don't know what kind of
leisurely things right like go fishing
right
go bowling whatever whatever sport
activities i don't know it's like it it
doesn't
it just doesn't cut it you gotta you
gotta you gotta do what's
what you're good at
what you love doing what you're you know
all of that in in in one thing and and
if you can go do that and i think
i think uh that would
make things meaningful it's it's it's
like
meaning of life is what's meaningful to
you you can anybody can make
meaning
out of anything like it
it only matters to you you know what i
mean like that makes sense
and and right now would you say with
everything going on would you say you're
pretty fulfilled
um
i'm okay i think i i would say after
after retiring i think i kind of like
went down in the toilet
yeah
like it i think i might have been like i
might have been a bit miserable at work
because of my job but then at least at
the time i was like happy kind of like
uh what do you call
uh
what you're just hustling yeah hustle
working yeah that was that was that was
a fun part and and sometime afterwards
but then i i think i think right when i
decided to to uh
retire quote unquote retire
that was when uh things things
kind of
went downhill it wasn't it wasn't fun
it it's fun for like you think it's fun
right for a little bit but everybody
would think it's fun yeah for like
what would you do if you don't have to
work for money right like
you know for me i you just do whatever
you want right you have you might have a
huge to-do list
you just i i like knocked every single
item off it's like oh i'm done with
everything
i ever need to do
and
that and then it's like okay now now
what do i do okay i'm going to twiddle
my thumb i'm going to paint paint the
paint the walls
yeah i guess i found found some stuff
that would occu might
occupy my time that thing that takes a
long time to do but then ultimately it
is like why why are you doing that
or why why was i doing that
oh
do you have any hobbies
yes what are they um i had too many
before
i've kind of narrowed them down because
uh
i don't know i guess i wasn't interested
in them as much anymore but uh they
include
uh
top of the list is fixing electronic
gadgets i love doing that like i have a
little lab at my house
with uh
you know electronic gear okay
uh
i like uh to go to the driving range
that's fun
uh like going camping
uh yeah
do you think that this feeling that you
had after retiring is a is like a
causation of early retirement or do you
think this is just how you treated early
retirement that led to you feeling like
this like not emptiness or anything to
be dramatic but just like this
unfulfillment
uh
i think
it's probably
it's probably
my fault i guess um because i think
when you retire you actually need
something
to retire too you need a plan to keep
you busy very busy
like
i guess maybe i didn't have a solid
enough a plan like uh
it just kind of fell into
fell into doing a little bit of youtube
and then a little less less less less
and then
and then uh you you end up well i end up
doing
just whatever it's like there wasn't any
any set goal or anything and i think
that's the
that's the drawback maybe if if you plan
on retire you have some side project
that you like a really big one that
would take up all your time i think that
would
that would help a lot what would you say
your next goal is do you have like a net
worth goal do you have a youtube goal
i wish i guess i wish to
to further my my channel
i'll tell you how you do that
finance content more financial i think
the frugal stuff the finance stuff is
all covered you've got that covered
kevin's got that kind of no but not in
the way that you do it that's what i'm
saying i think it's finance early
retirement frugal living i kind of if
you posted two video two to three videos
a week on those subjects
or
calculating out how much you could save
by
making small changes that everyone wants
to know about but they don't do it like
let's say uh doing a garden like instead
of going and buying a salad you now
make your own salad in the garden
buying a two-ply and then separating
versus doing one that's a great one
yeah and you like that one yeah you want
me to do that now
well i'm sure yeah yeah
you know be hilarious you've got ideas
like that that people are curious about
but wouldn't want to try on their own
ridiculous things that that uh
yeah yeah people might do drinking tap
water instead of bottled water i'm sure
there's a whole bunch of stuff
that uh
buying generic instead of name brands
but the thing is i think the the the
the very scrimping kind of videos are
are the ones that it doesn't do too well
actually for my my channel could be i'm
interested in this you
but maybe that's true
the broad financial topics i think if
you did that uh five hundred thousand
you could probably do that i would say
within the next uh six to twelve months
just posting three videos a week finance
and the rewards i love the credit card
rewards videos you did a video about
google pay
i liked that one where you get like a
instant twenty dollars for free i love
those videos
alex is a long term subscriber and he
said he was extremely excited to meet
you today do you have any input on this
subject alex was a huge fan by the way
so when i said we haven't beat the bush
coming else no way yeah yeah why thank
you alex thanks yeah i mean we have a
lot of uh similarities i also repair
electronics oh yeah awesome you know
sometimes i do i fix things that cost
too much like i'll sit there for two
hours when i could have bought it for
like 15 you know yeah well that's the
most satisfying
fix anything really keep it from the
landfill
exactly i agree
did you have any idea on where what
direction he could take his content in
i
i mean i think i'm one of the odd
viewers because i i watch him because of
the personality like when he attached a
cup to a gimbal i thought that was the
funniest thing i've ever seen i like
that one a lot running with it exactly
so like i'm not the right to be honest
for success you know i'm not the right
guy to ask but i just i value the
content alex will watch anything
thanks graeme
so what questions do you have for us do
you have anything for jack or i or alex
this is your chance to ask us any
questions if you have any i guess when i
make the finance videos i
kind of um
get bored of it but you you have this
this um drive
to
go at it to
keep on
hustling i don't know how you do it yeah
uh i don't know i have so much fun with
it though there are those videos where
i'm talking to jack i'm like i don't
want to make another
passive income video but they do well so
there are times i would say one video a
week is usually one of those ones where
i'm like i have to make a video on
something what's the most interesting
that i could do that honestly but you do
it anyway oh yeah
you're like uh
i don't know you got you got the got
that drive oh yeah yeah where does it
come from i don't know i won't let
myself miss a an upload part of it could
be
a minor like ocd there could be like
something in my brain because because i
cannot miss an upload i get panicky if i
if i ever get close to like
being behind or not posting i
i lose it like i will get an upload done
i i know i know the feeling and i used
to do yeah
i think yeah yeah
it's
i think i think it's after after um
uh reaching the retirement goal it's
like oh i missed one oh i missed another
one so that's what i've i've been
telling jack this too i am so afraid
because i've seen so many people go down
that path of just it all starts with
just missing one
nothing bad happened all right things
are pretty much the same not a big deal
it's easy to miss another one nothing
bad happened then it's like more
frequent more frequent than
you know what
and once you're off that uh
i don't want to call it a hamster wheel
but once you're off of that
it becomes that much harder to get back
on i think it's the same thing going to
the gym if you're at the gym every day
you're gonna keep going every day but as
long as soon as you give yourself that
excuse if i don't need to go today
it's easy to fall off and i know i i
can't keep up my current schedule once i
once i stop
i i i'm going to look back at this
because i don't know how i did it i have
no clue but you must have had some kind
of goal right and and you found huge
success so far you must have
it and beat it long ago oh yeah
but after you beat it then but then you
kept on going i just enjoy it
i just enjoy it yeah um
so i mean yeah there's a little bit of
diminishing returns at a certain point
but i have so much fun and uh
i i just now it's become more of like
not like not a game but uh i just i i
enjoy it i think it's fun i just think
it's really cool i think that's the
thing and uh yeah to
to really
be good at what you do yeah you gotta
you gotta really enjoy it yeah but then
it's also like the other benefits that
you get from it just um
getting to meet all these other people
that i wouldn't ordinarily get exposed
to
and uh learning different industries
like i'd have no idea about startups
like i'd have no clue how to get into
that but now i'm i've
started to get introduced to people who
are doing that and like creating their
own businesses and like that wouldn't
have been possible if it wasn't for
youtube so now the benefits of youtube
are like you're extending beyond just
how much money you would make but just
also than the connections and the
outreach that you could get
plus i just i have fun with it thank you
so much for coming on the podcast it is
an honor to meet you we really
appreciate it
and yeah this is really good you have no
idea because i i swear i've been
watching you for like five five and a
half years the very beginning you were
under 10 000 subscribers
it's this weird thing on youtube right
where like i'm on i'm on i see my videos
and i see your videos they're like oh
there he is and you must be like oh look
yeah it's like
you know you're on the internet and you
kind of see each other's stuff once in a
while yep no no so now we're here it's
cool and this is what i love about
youtube is that like i feel like i knew
you instantaneously like when you when
you showed up at the front door it's
like i already know who you are yeah and
like i feel like we're already friends
even though we hadn't ever met before
and it was just from seeing you on
youtube for like five years
thank you very much we appreciate it a
ton and uh yeah until next time guys
until next time thanks
cool
thank you so much that was easy
thanks for doing this